Hi guys I am at jonny's burger in The Hague
crook has launched his own citizen
so we are going to test it today
more than 200 civilians have been sold
something from Saturday this is with every johnny's
burger available
boom citizens please thank you
honestly you don't think he looks like Mario now
this is what the box looks like
looks nice but of course it's about the taste
there are chips in between
jalapeno peppers
and the meat in between is also super tasty
he was really 1 bit spicy
if you don't love it
you can always take it out
as you can see from my face it was certainly successful
I have to deliver something uh
but I am actually very curious
how do you taste it
he was very tasty
I give him 1 1 9
wow thank you
check the book better
she doesn't lie i don't lie